the big sunday show the biden
administration keeps blaming putin for
record high inflation but some in the
media are finally admitting what we have
all known all along it's because of
biden listen
if you look at the numbers
inflation really started to rise almost
exactly when when when biden came in the
white house i don't think people are
candidly that dumb i mean we remember
the inflation was going on long before
uh this happened to sort of whitewash
what happened all of last year i don't
think is going to work for them
politically
rachel i feel like a broken record but
they are saying it too your thoughts on
this it's ridiculous
so i first of all as a conservative it's
just so laughable what a light touch
they have with their criticism
i can't imagine a conservative in year
one having this entire disaster
including inflation which hits everybody
especially the poor in the middle class
and those on fixed income and getting
that kind of a light touch that said
perhaps what they're doing here is
allowing for criticism
in order to allow for another candidate
kamala will be tied to biden
and they just want to make sure they
kind of move them on admit that so maybe
some of the
the democrats running in the midterms
don't get um too smeared with all the
with all the muck and also make room for
a new candidate in 2024. yeah i want to
take a look at this montage because the
biden administration is pointing the
finger at putin and this is laughable
too
putin's war is already hurting american
families at the gas pump it is accurate
that the invasion by president putin
into ukraine has impacted global
inflation inflation in the united states
next month we'll see
a further evidence of
an impact on u.s inflation of
putin's war on
ukraine make no mistake inflation is
largely the fault of putin
charlie your take on this it started
when they started you know signing these
bills to spend trillions and trillions
of dollars that america didn't need at
that time to reopen
it's all such a lie and they're gonna do
everything they can depend just like
they pinned everything on covid before
they're gonna pin everything on putin
now um and it was sort of interesting
you saw uh yesterday both the white
house and nancy pelosi both put out
these completely bonkers tweets
yesterday about how inflation has
nothing to do with spending which is
just sort of breathtaking and i think i
think most regular americans realize
this and i think that's why they are so
scared and they're so furiously trying
to pin this on some anybody else other
than themselves because they know
they're going to pay a price for it and
griff when it comes to the economy i
mean a lot of americans do vote with
their pocketbook they didn't necessarily
last time but having said that once they
start to feel this they go to the polls
in the midterms and things may start to
change and this administration knows
that it's an old adage of politics and
it hadn't changed grab them by their
pocketbooks and their hearts and minds
will follow look let me tell you about
this putin price hike thing and how
effective that's doing i've been filling
my car up and it is very painful i have
not heard anybody cursing putin's name
at a gas station but i've heard a lot of
cursing going on when people are filling
their tanks up so they may want to try a
different thing and roll out a new
boogie man because vlad isn't going to
stick as the target rachel in the last
20 seconds that we have left you
mentioned your nine children when you
have a family that large and you're
paying more for groceries and gas and
everything else that they need i mean it
must be very daunting
it is but i tell you every day that i
complain about it i think about those
elderly people on fixed incomes and they
just have nowhere to go they can't go to
their boss and ask for a raise um and
often they're already living
hand-to-mouth um as it is so uh there's
nothing for them to do and there's no
there's no indication at all that biden
wants to change his mind um at all on
any of these policies so unfortunately
jackie just more to come hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else